why is it important to have a top-level
chess tournament for women here in the
United States because this is the first
time and I'm hope it's will be you will
continue this tradition and we need to
attract more ghosts to play chess and to
have more role models in one spot for
two weeks that's just wonderful the more
tournaments like that you have you can
train because when your train is not so
strong people you cannot you know just
go up so that's why it's great yeah it's
the first time so I think it's really
very important for women chess you know
there's no many women tournaments in the
world so it's very important for us to
play more top tournaments to develop
women chess okay actually that's my
first tournament when I'm playing around
with round-robin and against such a
strong players women chess players
yeah well I'm really happy that um st.
Louis has finally gotten to this kind of
events you know I mean they've added so
many great tournaments to their calendar
since beginning to host the US
Championships here in 2009 and there
really just hasn't been a great
round-robin like this for a long time
you know and so I haven't just haven't
had that many opportunities to play
tournaments like this and it's great to
showcase all these different ladies from
around the world and in their talents to
a wider public unfortunately we don't
have such a strong many many many
tournaments like this especially in the
private of women tournament where there
is a high high prices we don't have so
much so what I like it
it happens here now and I'm part of it I
heard about this tournament and I read
about this tournament and when I was
invited I was so positively surprised
because for me is one of the strongest
women's tournament applied in my life
and I never really had a chance in my
life to participate in any crime free
and this tournament my strengths is just
like a crime-free so for me personally
it's like the best New Year's upcoming
invitation I could possibly get so I'm
very very happy that this tournament is
its fault
yes it's a it's a it's good to play in
in some way for me it's a very good
opportunity so I am very happy to join
suit on I want and I have to play good
in this on a mountain it will be very
good experience for me
but it's of course like a really great
start for women's just to have a super
women tournament with a very good price
fun and especially st. Louis because we
have been like all these years we heard
about how brilliant the organization is
and like we have the best tournament in
the world so it's definitely a privilege
for us to have the women tournament
started here a closed tournament of such
caliber so I mean I think it's a great
great milestone for women's chest in us
and hopefully it just the beginning of a
new chest tradition that will definitely
add help and support women's chests in
US and worldwide
you